the things I do for you guys the
director of Mortal Kombat annihilation
presents you guys seen that atrocity
oh [ __ ] now almost two decades later
this guy's now directing this movie so
Annabel's is essentially a prequel to
the conjuring it revolves around the
little creepy doll from the conjuring
actually is probably closer to a prequel
to a haunted house to because it's the
same doll now gonna lie when I saw the
doll I could have thought of two things
the conjuring or the scene from a
haunted house - I've thought of that
second one have some halfway-decent
actors get terrorized by some really
creepy [ __ ] happening I think life will
be good alright you don't want to follow
that formula all right well I guess
we'll just make Annabelle seriously the
main actress in this who are these
people they have the looks of
high-quality porn and the acting range
of low-quality porn it's good I mean
they're attractive people and the dude
looks like a stuntman he's like oh yeah
I'm friends with the director or some
[ __ ] in life it's not what you know it's
who you know kids remember that rule but
it's alright we're gonna have some
really creepy and a Bella's [ __ ]
happening for the first hour of this
movie nothing happened just a lot of
shots of the creepy dolls fate I can do
that here that's right guys I'm the
director now when [ __ ] starts happening
is like OLF popcorn on the stove and
then the stove turns on the popcorn
catches on fire I was like really the
intro to scream one we're going hear
people doing stupid stuff people making
stupid-ass decision so when things start
going down now you know creepy shit's
happening she's like get rid of that
doll he gets rid of the doll and the
doll comes back cuz it's you know a
possessed boomerang doll I guess any
guys like I thought I threw it out
look let's burn it or something she's
like now she knows by now every time
there's a creepy s sound or a creaky
sound or a rocking chair sound down the
hallway he'll walk towards it every time
like a moth to flame she walks towards
it yeah let's not learn from our
mistakes it's something smart people do
there is a scene in a basement where
[ __ ] started happening I thought that
was cool cuz you actually see the demon
that I'm gonna call dark Tumnus you know
in zelda there's a link in Dark Link you
know dark links like evil link this we
have Tumnus and we have dark dumbness
this movie has dark dumbness you see
dark toughness you're like that's
actually the creepiest thing this
happens the first creepy thing that's
happened in the movie sorry it happened
an hour and 20 minutes into the movie
but glad that's happening now I mean it
was effective when I saw it but in the
end it's just it's nothing special as
much as I enjoy that enjoyed the fact
that there's thunder and lightning in
the staircases she's running from him in
thunder and lightning in the staircase
think about that it's why I started
driving home and I started
deconstructing dark Tumnus
I was like wait a minute dark time this
wasn't actually the demon that was
latched on to the doll in the conjuring
this is a prequel to the conjuring why
does the demon look different is the
demon different think the demons are all
sitting around like hey you mind if I
use the doll today no it's fine go head
okay I'm just gonna you know just this
one family you can get the next family
you know because you look creepy too
alright I'm gonna you know pleasing
destiny yeah you can play some destiny
if you want you don't have to wait for
me I mean we can play destiny when I get
back my neck up already is that what
they do is that where we're at in this
whole franchise in the end Annabelle had
one creepy part in the movie and after
you start deconstructing it you're like
alright well that's just gone a lady
walking with long dark hair lady being
creepy with long dark hair we're not
past this we're still on the ring movie
would have had his saving grace if it
had good actors in it but the movie
didn't have good actors in it this movie
conjured one thing and that is the fact
that Annabelle is dog [ __ ] so have you
seen Annabelle what did you think about
it or you thought comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]